very bad all right hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
mario kart i'm in ethan's apartment
taking over his whole recording station
uh like i do so uh we're gonna get into
it we just got done with a video over on
his channel so you can check that out
link in the description
um we're doing 50cc yeah gonna do better
gonna win every game as a big ass
juxtaposition between
50cc and uh [ __ ] this one
or 260 and [ __ ] this one this one cc
is much faster
yeah my my problem with it i i did towed
last time but i i
didn't change up the setup because
toad's all about speed
that's why i could never catch up to you
because i was all about acceleration but
toad
it doesn't work that way you got to have
you got to max out your speed
rookie mistake rookie mistake
ready for the ride of your life yeah
yeah i think i am okay which one you
want to do
uh any of them that we haven't done
yet
i could do that yeah i love eggs
egg cups
you know i get it like like a lot of
jokes that go around at markiplier hq i
get it i just don't feel the need to
laugh
at it it wasn't even a joke it was just
like it's egg cup and i was like oh i
love eggs
this is such an honest like statement
you're like hey i'm gonna present my
my love of eggs to mark here and i hope
he reciprocates
you don't share the love of eggs no i
[ __ ] it no i didn't
do good you look good man you gotta
believe in yourself more oh
sis hey buddy hey
i'm gonna drift off [ __ ] did i [ __ ]
things up again oh god do backwards
shooting pieces [ __ ] oh you met a lady
have you ever felt the rush of a green
shell pop out your ass
into another soul you know i can't say
honestly i have
but i guess when we're shooting them
forward we're shooting them out of our
dick with that same logic so
that have you ever sounded a super show
sounding i i had to explain
sounding to ethan from h3d straight
like if there was ever a guy and i don't
know what this says but he didn't put
him like
i just expected him to know what
sounding was wait
sound sounding is similar to docking
right i guess
sounding is when you stick things down
your urethra
yeah yeah yeah so it's like docking but
without another dick
yeah well you are way way way ahead
i've got the speed on my side
oh sorry i was wrong it doesn't help
that i'm hitting
every [ __ ] banana but he didn't he
didn't did he know about docking
i didn't ask him it didn't come up in
the conversation oddly enough
you know but it was super weird like i
didn't expect anybody uh like
like i love going on that podcast by the
way because i love any opportunity to
just talk about how weird youtube
is i literally thought that you were
gonna say
i love any opportunity to talk about
myself
i mean that too you know that too no but
like
it's it was just a really cool
conversation to have with um
you know with these guys that i respect
so much and it's it's just fun because
it's it's a it is a weird job that we
have it's
weird what we do and uh gotta take
enjoyment where you can out of it and
not take it too seriously all the time
which is a mistake that a lot of people
do they take youtube way too seriously
as if it's a competition as if it's like
yeah
people are actually what's weird is like
in this last year it's turned into more
of a celebrity fest
than it has like it used to be like you
know there was always a little bit of
celebrity status here and there but
uh lately oh you got you got a whole lot
of [ __ ] you coming your way
oh no you got like a leg oh no oh
no that was two in a row i don't think
it's going to impede your lead though
you are just
blazing past everybody how are you so
[ __ ] up
no i don't know yeah
i've got so much skills this is still
the first
map i feel like we've been playing for
years i mean we've been having a good
old time here
yeah gandering talking about goo a lot
talking about no we're not making any
goo jokes this time
it was your decision you were the one
that said no
if anybody's been following this chain
of uh i hit you with a red shell after
you go
through there yeah if anyone's been
following the goo
through the trail of goo
how do you if you want to find out where
either mark or i live just
follow the gu it'll lead you straight to
us
oh yeah it's funny it's actually
disgusting if you think about
it really because like i can't tell what
the analogy is anymore
it was just for interpretation is a
ubiquitous goo
could be anything it could be any kind
of then a rapper
rapidly deteriorated a semen and so on
but now i'm not maybe
you get your mind out of the gutter i'm
sorry
i'm not okay okay okay here we go here
we go
i gotta get myself in the game oh game
face game face game please
you think you're going to slay some puss
when you beat 50 cc
dude all the posts like did you see how
many ladies were in my apartment when
you walked in
no yeah that's because you can't see
them
they're visible they're invisible dude
no
oh no okay
i thought that was coming my way no i'm
not
fine i don't care about that i was just
worried about myself this is spooky
spooky trails i don't like this
i don't like
we're this we're talking about what
we're doing the difference between goo
and semen
and how much puss you're gonna sleep
yeah oh yeah because i'm a youtube
celebrity
right it's exactly what we're talking
about yeah that's how it works man
that's how it works
oh no i didn't use it close enough
man the table is turned i am now
in the winner yeah oh oh oh you've got
another
thing yes buckaroo oh
what is my mom flying all the way from
me to come over to talk to me about
an issue so pressing i don't wanna i
don't wanna
cover that topic you've gotta come over
and talk to you about your rude goo
i just imagine you you know cause i know
i know
your grandma watches like a lot of these
videos
it's just like i think back to the
grandma's
recipe and i'm just so sorry
wait grandma's oh no that one
was that on my channel i mean it doesn't
even matter because she watched both of
our channels
oh she's such a dedicated fan she is
she's so sweet
she watches each of her videos every
single day yeah all of them i met her
she was the nicest
yeah she was asking all sorts of
questions she was so excited
you're crawling up my ass oh yeah get
ready
get ready get ready i'm ready
i'm ready
[Music]
get blocked no yeah that's right i know
the mad skills with the block and greens
oh [ __ ] yeah get back there oh this girl
only went to one side of me
oh yes he's running low on goo
you gotta help him
goku with the spirit you can lend
he did like the spirit bomb in like
every episode i never watched dragon
ball
really no what
no never it's impossible
it's not possible for me to watch dragon
ball
yeah no i never i watched like an
episode here or there but i never like
watched it just watch dbz bridge like
you'll get the whole story and you'll
laugh
way harder along the way but like an
appreciation for dragon ball and dragon
ball z and
now dragon ball super which i i'm
fascinated and i'm still watching dragon
ball super
because i really do still watching to
this day yeah well they're coming out
with new episodes with dragon ball super
because they started it back
up like three years ago and i've been
watching
[Music]
[Laughter]
i've been watching like and i'm actually
shocked because i did not think that i
was gonna be watching it
but it's not good but it's just like hey
it's more dragon ball it's not bad
either
yeah it's not it's not the worst that it
could be
is there a lot worse face than what
happened to tv shows that go home way
too long
yeah which speaking of which i need to
watch all of the simpsons
i do yeah i really do because i've never
actually watched
like sat down and like plowed through
all the episodes
did you ever watch it like when it was
in its prime i tried
um not in its prime definitely but i
like i tried to catch episodes where i
could but like tv was just never a big
thing in our household like even before
the days of netflix
yeah please tell me that hit you nope
nothing goddamn it
nothing no stole my soul
i would never never take that from you
oh you got another [ __ ] no you can have
first
[ __ ] hell oh whoa
that green shell like
or no i'm not even a toad i'm a [ __ ]
mushroom or no i'm a human with a
mushroom infecting my brain
according to the game theory is that
matpat's game theory not that yeah
according to matpat and a large subset
of the internet
i'm always watching
baby
i've never actually hit someone with
that thing you've never hit
anyone no i probably should have saved
it for another blue shield but i was too
satisfying man i don't think you can get
rid of it with the blue shell yeah no
that is
actually the blue shell get rid of thing
the horn
yeah that's exactly what it's meant for
the horn
god damn it are we really only a lapid
[Music]
oh my
[Music]
[Music]
no you can't you can't beat this oh no
in a blue shirt
okay i thought that was coming for me if
i get if i got
it's so different so much slower
oh boy what if we could tie our next
race if i get ready
first yeah go for it try mm-hmm try and
try my darndest
all right i'm gonna fight your tooth and
nail all right all right
all right bite you down to the bone last
one last one of my favorite eggs
i think that's i think i think this
whole arc of episodes is the fastest
we've ever killed a joke
the goo it's already dead it's already
gone from the very beginning of the
first episode to now
and then just like yeah okay i don't
even remember where it originated
oh dude
[Laughter]
a true mystery a true mystery maybe
we'll never know
one of the eight mysteries of the world
eight seven
seven wonders of the world is the eighth
in my book oh thank you
thank you so much i don't think it does
i think you're lying
you don't know how much your goon means
to me i i don't wanna know
but you could if you wanted you know a
disgusting thing have you ever seen like
uh the 4chan
things about like the kum box and like
the uh the
the person that saved get blown by that
oh the person that saved their comfort
years yeah in bottles
it's so weird right like saving your
tears for your husband at war
you know about that no yeah back in the
olden days when uh
when women's husband women's husbands
used to go to
war [ __ ] yeah when they used to go to
war they used to save their tears and
bottles to show how much they cried for
them while they were away
just be weirded out yeah it's super
[ __ ] weird because it would like get
discolored after a while and it'd just
be like
i would come back and be like you could
complain
like what if amy wasn't coming on tour
with us and she was here and you just
she saved all of her tears for you while
we're on tour
oh boy some for people to talk about i
guess yeah
i guess i'd make a video about it you
know kind of capitalize on it
hey guys that's my videos yeah you know
me
just want to get real with you for a
second
amy saved her tears for me you guys
wouldn't do that
wait are you putting it from a good
perspective or a bat am i proud of this
or
i don't know would you be proud of it i
would be i would admire like the
dedication but also i'd be very
concerned because that's a lot of crying
well i mean you don't know how much see
that's the thing is like the husbands
would come back and measure how much
their their woo man cried for them
yeah and if it wasn't enough
like that's the first thing coming back
from the harrowing journey of war like
woman show me the jar
[Laughter]
you've been dodging bullets all through
germany and then all of a sudden just
like
your first thought yes not a home-cooked
meal
it's a home-cooked meal and then to
drink it down with even a home-cooked
meal
like don't even give her a hug just
where's my food and where are your tears
i need to see them pronto
stewart's wife cried gallons for him
what have you got you got him killed oh
[ __ ] oh no i think you're still too far
ahead
yeah i think you got it yes does that
mean we tied i think we did unless i get
[ __ ] over this because i'm very slow
right now
nope okay let's see i think we tied it i
think we're tired yep
we died you time for first ah that's
something nice
no one knows
[ __ ] all right this was a later i want
to see
what this is all about oh [ __ ] wait you
want me to slow it down for you yeah
there we go
what if we watch the entire race
oh that's pretty cool wow wow
good stuff all right cool
i think we have to watch this whole
thing wait
this is super cool my
bonkers you're metal bunkers
yeah i don't know why you were so fast
that was really nice
yeah because because like i was able to
get you with with like items and skill
things like that and then like you just
pull away peach's body just very slender
and aerodynamic i'd like to think so
i'd [ __ ] metal peach
[Laughter]
would you leave me for metal pieces in a
heartbeat and she'd expect it she'd
leave me for metal mario
well we all know that you'd leave each
other for bowser any day oh
[ __ ] yeah that thorn that
horn bush so good
really gets me grumbling
all right you get you satisfied yep oh
am i ever wait no hang on wait god damn
it
uh she doing with her hands
are you ripping apart a pair of screws
anyway so all right view results all
right sure
we could have continued watching if we
wanted to we could have and you guys
would have asked for
it but yeah i'll laughs we will go we've
gotta go i gotta go all right
let's see on the podium oh boy
they don't show up i love the podium and
getting the uh the the theo
the vine stock when you get like a
perfect score yeah that was always my
favorite
they don't do anything cause like i
didn't know what that was there was like
no strategy guys and then
just that happened one day i'm like
thomas
i called him jason at the time a [ __ ]
vine
just a little music what is your
brother's name not thomas
yeah his name is jason his middle name's
thomas
i change everything i know about your
brother which is so much
we've been so close for years and years
and you never told me
ah vehicle customization
what is goop everywhere goop no
goo move to goop yeah they'll be next
time that'll be the joke for next time
yeah sure alright
save it savor it all right well thanks
for letting me hang out yeah
play games it was fun uh we're gonna go
on tour after this
yeah literally that's the next thing
we're doing well i mean by the time this
comes out we're probably there
yeah probably we're done yes so check
out ethan's stuff in the description
below we already did a video before this
so i'll put a link to that as well
and thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always we will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
oh